we have a voicemail number it is two one
nine two david p let's take a listen to
this voicemail see what you think
hey david this is Joshua rose I'm from
Georgia and Tom price is actually my
representative yeah and I work in a
manufacturing plant as an engineer with
a lot of people who voted for Trump when
do you believe that the supporters will
actually get with the program and
understand it been bamboozled thank you
probably never we've talked about this
Pat and Ben had a great clip about this
the day that Ben filled in for me when I
was away a couple weeks ago and we've
talked about it many times I don't know
that the trumpets in in total will ever
admit or agree that they've been
bamboozled because they are so invested
in the idea of Trump is the savior he
will make America great again after
President Obama destroyed the country
they've built up this whole narrative
that I don't know that they could allow
themselves to admit that they've been
bamboozled some will we've heard about
Trump Gretz
on Twitter most of them won't yes some
will some won't I think one of the
biggest reasons people are backtracking
from their support of Donald Trump was
seeing his cabinet picks people like Rex
Tillerson the oil tycoons and Finance
ears they're just not having it the the
swamp just got ten feet deeper that's
what I like to say in response to that
the wall is getting 10 feet higher on
the bonus show today maybe we are
getting to the end of dentists doing
normal cavity fillings as scientists
find an Alzheimer's medication makes
teeth grow back also problems for Donald
Trump a new poll shows that only 22
percent of the US wants Obamacare
completely repealed that's not good when
you ran your campaign on repealing
Obamacare and also who's doing what for
the inauguration also we are 24 hours
away roughly 30 hours away from the end
of the crowdfunding IndieGoGo campaign
to fight back against the war on media
of the incoming Trump administration
supporting independent progressive media
we're doing a lot of really great things
I encourage you to at minimum read about
them at david pakman.com slash donate if
it sounds worthwhile make it
whether it's a dollar or $100 if there's
a hidden thirty thousand dollar donation
waiting out there pat by all means make
it you can check out a list of all the
great perks that are available and we
I'm so grateful to the nearly five
hundred donors that have already
contributed during the last few weeks of
the campaign thirty hours to go maybe
twenty four by the time you hear this
david pakman.com slash donate last thing
membership membership has been and will
continue to be the number one funding
source for the show if you were not a
member and the normal rates are high
sign up for our newsletter at david
pakman.com because tomorrow a very dark
day in American history we will be
sending out an email blast with a huge I
mean just absolutely huge membership
special and if you want to be notified
about that all you have to do is sign up
for our newsletter at david pakman.com
that's it for today we will talk to you
on the bonus show and talk to you
tomorrow the day of donald trump's
inauguration